So here's one way to solve the question:
we're going to define a procedure,
so we'll define a procedure, is_friend.
It takes a single string as input.
We'll call that the name--that's the name of the person.
We're going to do a test using an "if" statement.
We'll test if the first character of name is equal to an upper case "D".
If it is, that means the person's a friend,
so we can return True.
If it's not--they're not a friend--
we don't need the "else", right--we could just have our return False.
I'm going to keep things more symmetric by using an "else"
and if the name does not start with a "D", we can return False.
So let's try that.
With our example, ('Diane'), we get is_friend is True,
and when we try with ('Fred'), we get the output, False.
So this looks like what we want.
This is actually a lot more code than we need.
There's no reason we have to actually have the "if" expression.
Since the test itself evaluates to a Boolean
we could just return right away.
We could return the result of the comparison.
We're doing the equality test,
if name, index zero--the first character of name--is equal to "D".
So this has the same meaning, much simpler thing.
Sometimes people think it's unnatural to write expressions like this,
that when you have test conditions,
you feel like you need an "if" statement--but it's not required.
It's much simpler, in this case, to just have the one line
where we return the result of the equality test, directly.